I uh I don't even know how to explain
this to you
but there is yet another report
that Donald Trump has talked about
fantasizing
about sex with his own daughter Ivanka
Trump and I know that there are people
who may not realize that this isn't new
I told you about this a long time ago
this is not a new thing remember that
clip I used to play where Trump says you
know if Ivanka weren't my daughter
perhaps I would be dating her and Trump
on the Howard Stern Show talking about
his daughter as a piece of ass
um this is actually not new but there is
a new report about it uh this is a this
is an article from Newsweek
a trump made shocking comments about
Ivanka says an ex-staffer these are
claims from Miles Taylor Miles Taylor is
the former Trump Administration official
who wrote that that scathing op-ed about
Trump under the pen name anonymous
Taylor was a former Chief of Staff is a
former Chief of Staff at the Department
of Homeland Security
and he describes a number of different
incidents in his forthcoming book
blowback where Trump made women
uncomfortable
and the article says these incidents
included claims by AIDs that Trump made
lewd comments about his daughter
ivanka's appearance and talked about
what it might be like
to have sex with her
this prompted a rebuke from his own
Chief of Staff according to the book
this is not
um there are a whole bunch of other
examples
this
this is not new
okay we have a clip here I'm going to
play
I'll just present the clip without
comment but Trump's obsession with his
own daughter and his own daughter's body
is not a new thing to anybody who's been
paying attention what's the favorite
thing you have in common Donald with
your daughter well I was going to say
sex but I can't relate that by the way
your daughter she's beautiful
can I say this a piece of
piece of it very voluptuous she's six
feet tall she's got the best body she's
hot I've said that if Ivanka weren't my
daughter perhaps I'd be dating her
it's so weird
this is this is not normal this is weird
it's extremely weird this this is this
is sick it's sick Woody Allen
people are clapping now
ivanka's clapping but looks quite
uncomfortable so listen
um I mean Trump's not fit to be
president regardless of this is the
reality and I got dozens of emails about
this half saying David can you believe
this crap can you believe how sick this
guy is and the other half saying this
doesn't have any bearing whatsoever if
Trump's foreign policy was good why
would he why would we care that he finds
his daughter attractive my view is sort
of in the middle in the sense that
regardless of his views about his
daughter's attractiveness Trump is not
fit to be president of the United States
in addition this is so mind-bendingly
creepy that it only furthers any normal
person's uh
reaction that there's something the the
what would we say the wheel is spinning
but the hamster is dead maybe is the
phrase that I would use something is
very wrong with this guy and they talk
about grooming and this that and the
other thing this is borderline predatory
behavior but very important not new
information and I know people will
people are already commenting and a
couple wrote To Me saying this is this
is just so ridiculous it's so not
believable it's nothing like Trump
this is just a corroboration of the type
of thing Trump has said five six seven
times in history it's disgusting I think
we're going to move on from it uh and
leave it there make sure you're
subscribed by the way on YouTube we have
seen in the last 36 to 48 hours maybe
thanks to Howard Stern's endorsement a
significant acceleration in the fight
for 2 million YouTube subscribers help
us get there more than 3 million people
in May watched our YouTube clips and did
not subscribe all I'm asking you is for
something that's free just hit that
subscribe button let's get to 2 million
let's do it folks whether you're a
carpenter painter or just want to be
prepared for emergencies if you need a
gas mask or respirator go to our sponsor
parcel safety as many of you know I'm
into emergency preparedness not crazy
prepping but I want to have some food
stored some supplies I've talked about
water and multiple respirators are part
of that because it's just a staple of
being prepared respirator sales have
been way up in recent years natural
disasters wildfires polluted air
chemical plant accidents unrest of
different kinds militarized police all
sorts of different reasons you never
know when a respirator or a gas mask
from parcel safety might come in handy
and it could be when you least expect it
parcel safety respirators are also
perfect for professionals contractors
painters people doing DIY projects at
home all of parcel safety's respirators
come with a one-year manufacturer's
warranty every respirator or gas mask
comes with a filter competitive prices
large discounts for organizations and
outstanding customer service to be
totally honest I've said before I'm
using these for changing baby diapers
people think I'm kidding and then they
come visit me and I really am not it
actually is is very useful to other
parents out there I do recommend it go
to davidpackman.com safety use the code
Pacman for 25 off your first order the
link is down below